sono sempre stato affascinato da da
piccolo dalle storie dei grandi
personaggi che hanno lasciato un segno
nella storia indipendentemente che
fossero pittori o sportivi o anche
imprenditori i miei idoli erano tipo
steve jobs michael jordan john lennon e
quindi volevo capire cosa accomunasse
queste persone questi personaggi che
hanno lasciato il segno perché anch'io
volevo fare volevo lasciare il segno e
mi accorsi che tantissimi di questi
personaggi avevano avuto un'infanzia
molto difficile spesso avevano avuto
anche un rapporto con i genitori molto
complicato e sembrava quasi fosse il
motore che generava in loro quella
spinta ad uscire a fare delle cose in
più ad emergere
io però avevo un grosso problema che la
mia vita arabella e quindi vento cazzo è
perché la mia vita andava bene non avevo
problemi e in più il rapporto con i miei
genitori era perfetto io provavo a dire
no ci deve essere qualcosa trovato anche
chiedere a mia mamma mamma ma a me puoi
dirlo dai col papa ha battuto bene
lei mi fa guarda stefano io mi sono
innamorato del papa
il primo giorno che l'ho visto è oggi è
come fosse quel giorno ma che tu e non
ce la farò mai a diventare qualcuno però
è successa una cosa che mentre diventavo
adolescente anch'io
cominciavo ad avere una maturità che
cresceva una velocità superiore ai miei
coetanei quindi ero veramente molto più
maturo della mia età tanto che a 14 anni
volevo già fare un gesto che solitamente
non si fa a quell'età e quindi volevo
esprimere ai miei genitori
già il mio livello di maturità e ero
anche messo una situazione dove volevo
essere riconoscente quindi o seduto i
miei genitori in cucina
mia madre maestra di elementari da 40
anni in europa un direttore commerciale
di una importante azienda e gli disse
mamma papà grazie e è giunto il momento
io ho già deciso cosa voglio fare da
grande la mamma ovviamente era già con
le lacrime agli occhi e gli ho detto io
voglio fare il dj
mia mamma ovviamente se il figlio che ho
sempre voluto
non vedo l'ora di raccontare le mie
colleghe domani e quindi mentre i miei
genitori erano distratti dal capire cosa
avevano sbagliato con me nella vita io
cominciai cominciai a lavorare nei club
di domenica pomeriggio dove c'erano
tutti i miei amici i compagni di scuola
e tutto e poi iniziai anche a a suonare
nei club di sera e decisero anche di
pagarmi e quindi quello è successo che
io ho detto aspetta
io vado in questo posto loro mi danno i
soldi hanno ufficializzato che ero
entrato nel mondo del lavoro
cioè io avevo il mio primo lavoro e
quindi ho detto a questa cosa qua del
lavoro è una figata pazzesca certo
praticamente fai quello che ti piace
cioè la gente che che urla che si
diverte le donne che cominciano a
girarci intorno
poi non succede niente però intanto ti
girano intorno e di in più ti pagano
ok bellissimo ho fatto un po di anni
così fino a che a 18 anni la mia
maturità continuava a crescere e ho
letto allora ho fatto i geometri a schio
ho fatto 8 anni di francese
ok ho messo via 800 euro penso ci siano
i presupposti per trasferirsi a los
angeles e quindi
e mia mamma convince anche sua sorella
che quella vuole andare a lavorare in
banca a porta tra via conte passerà a
questo momento e ho fatto questa
esperienza in in california
ok e per me è stata un'esperienza
incredibile perché sono andato a vivere
in california e a lavorare anche nel
mondo sempre della musica per me era
stata una cosa incredibile perché cosa
mi era successo dal momento in cui mi
svegliavo per me era tutto nuovo era
tutto diverso
quella cosa che mi ricordo è che dicevo
una quantità esagerata di sì perché
qualsiasi cosa bisognava provare e
testare andare a vedere io dicevo sempre
sì poi cosa successe che a un certo
punto come a tutti come a tutte le
persone normali
mi arriva una cosa molto brutta che mi
stoppa gli stoppa mi blocca e quindi mi
sono accorto che mi aveva bloccato mi
aveva terminato un flusso che io avevo
iniziato da quando avevo 14 anni
in quel momento io dovevo prendere una
decisione per la mia vita del tipo ok
ricomincio da capo
cosa faccio devo trovarmi un nuovo
lavoro
il problema è che dentro di me io avevo
memorizzato che per me il lavoro era vi
ricordate gente che ti pagano solo che
delle persone a fianco me comincia una
dirgli stefano mi sa che tu hai visto un
bel mondo mi sa che la vita è un'altra
cosa
e sa che quali magnagatti lo vedo un po
creativo mi dicevano e io ho detto
eccolo lì il creativo ecco cosa sono
perché non capivo chi ero io sono un
creativo e quindi io da grande voglio
fare il direttore creativo che cosa vuol
dire non avevo la più pallida idea ma
suonava fighissimo cioè mi vedevo già il
biglietto da vista
allora dico ma cos'è la la creatività la
creatività è quel attitudine nel trovare
una risposta o una soluzione non
convenzionale erroneamente questa cosa
l'attribuiamo spesso a pittori musicista
gli artisti ma la creatività è un è un
comportamento ce l'abbiamo dentro ce
l'abbiamo sempre avuto
è un po come l'arroganza noi tutti
sappiamo cos'è l'arroganza noi tutti
abbiamo dentro l'arroganza quello che fa
la differenza è la quantità di volte che
la utilizziamo o se decidiamo appunto di
utilizzarla se utilizziamo l'arroganza
creeremo dei flussi arroganti se
utilizziamo la creatività generale mo
dei flussi creativi allora uno dice ma
cos'è un un flusso creativo il flusso
creativo si spiega meglio cercando di
capire cosa succede quando ci sei dentro
un flusso creativo
quando sei dentro un flusso creativo si
genera una sensazione di estasi perché
stai facendo quella cosa che più ti
piace nella vita avete presente la
sensazione del tempo che vola è un po
come fare sesso col tempo la penso che
l'esempio che tutti noi possiamo
immaginare per capire cos'è un flusso
creativo è quando facciamo un viaggio
quando facciamo un viaggio cosa che
succede
c'è dal mattino quando ci svegliamo alla
sera tutto quello intorno a noi cambia
cambiano i panorami cambiano i colori
cambiano la lingua i gusti i sapori i
colori non ci sono più le nostre
abitudini e noi senza accorgersi cosa
succede abbiamo un nostro nuovo una
nostra nuova area di confort
cioè noi ci sentiamo normali nel provare
a fare tutte le cose nuove e sono le
vacanze sono quelle cose o i viaggi sono
quelle cose che generano a noi quegli
impulsi dove ci fanno comperare dei
cappelli non so perché compriamo i
cappelli quando andiamo in vacanza che
sono cappelli veramente ridicoli che ci
spingono a fare delle foto imbarazzanti
il bello del viaggio secondo me è che ci
insegna a a innamorarsi di tutto ciò che
non si conosce
in uno di questi viaggi
ero con due miei amici che per
semplicità chiamo marco e giovanni e mi
ricordo che a un certo punto lo nomino
ristorante e marco mi prendi un foglio
bianco un e con un pennarello nero fa un
punto in mezzo al foglio e mi chiede
stefano cosa vedi
ha diretto il punto nero e lui mi fa era
anche abbastanza orgoglioso
ecco vedi che ho dimostrato cosa succede
nella vita normale
cioè tu vedi un punto nero e ti
concentri su quello e non ti sei accorto
dei milioni di punti bianchi che avevi
attorno
io rimasi di così gli ho detto ma sai
che pazzesca statura che mi hai fatto
capire come potrei avere un punto di
vista diverso anche su delle cose
davvero banali però non fu quella la
lezione che ricevetti quel giorno perché
la lezione mi arrivò 5 secondi dopo dal
mio amico giovanni e giovanni mi disse
dai scott non ci credo che non l'avevo
mai sentita questa cosa qua del foglio
bianco quel punto nero cioè la sanno
tutti è vecchia veramente come la storia
eccoli io devo ringraziare molto
giovanni perché in quel momento lui mi
insegnò a come io non avrei mai voluto
essere nella vita perché non avrei mai
voluto essere una persona che abusa dei
no perché i no si presentano davvero in
molte in molte forme
io ho conosciuto tre tipi di persone
nella mia vita che mi hanno parecchio
colpito le prime sono le persone
ordinarie che conducono una vita
ordinaria questa tendenzialmente si
creano un'area di confort immediatamente
spesso succede subito dopo la scuola e
poi per tutta la vita anche con passione
cercano di proteggere quest'area di
confort
diciamo che non sono molto propense al
al cambiamento
la seconda tipologia di persone che mi
ha davvero colpito e delle persone
straordinarie però costrette a vivere
una vita straordinaria
spesso queste persone sono le persone
famose che nella vita hanno fatto hanno
realizzato un qualcosa che li ha
posizionati nell'olimpo quindi
paradossalmente la loro area di confort
sta là in alto e quindi tutte le persone
loro stessi compresi hanno bisogno da
loro sempre il massimo quindi vivono
costantemente con un quotidiano molto
complicato perché perché devono cercare
sempre di o di rimanerci la o di
ritornare e poi la terza la terza
categoria questi sono le mie proprio le
mie perché io questi li adoro
perché questi sono le persone ordinarie
che vivono però una vita straordinaria
queste persone hanno due caratteristiche
principali la prima è che hanno la piena
consapevolezza del valore del tempo e la
seconda invece è che sono affetti da neo
tenia allora la neo tenia ciò significa
neo tenia la neo tenera e mantenere le
caratteristiche dell'età infantile in
età adulta
significa che tu da adulto presenti
delle caratteristiche del tipo stupore e
curiosità meraviglia
etimologicamente neutrini a significa
tendenza alla gioventù e è ovvio che per
una persona come me era abbastanza
automatico il collegamento tra neo tenia
e creatività allora però mi sono chiesto
ma se abbiamo detto che la creatività ce
l'abbiamo da quando nasciamo ce
l'abbiamo tutti la conosciamo ce
l'abbiamo dentro come mai cosa succede
nel percorso che facciamo mentre
diventiamo adulti ma è una cosa molto
molto semplice
succede che nel momento in cui tu
cominci a non utilizzare una cosa nella
tua vita hai bisogno di fare un po di
ordine
quindi cosa fai tu metti la tua
creatività e in una scatola e dice sai
cosa io questa scatola la metto nel mio
garage la metto la la parcheggio poi un
giorno quando mi servirà andrò a
riprenderla però cosa succede che giorno
dopo giorno
io ne ricevo tantissime di scatole ok
che sono i classici condizionamenti no
perché mi arrivano delle scatole del
tipo lo guarda stefano però che la vita
non è proprio così semplice
mi danno questa scatola io la guardo
dico non so cosa farmene vado nel mio
garage e cominciò a depositare
poi mi dicono stefano mi raccomando mai
lasciare la strada vecchia per quella
nuova me ne faccio di questa cosa però
prendo la scatola è l'ambito in garage e
cominciò è ma c'è la crisi
emma non è il momento è ma non sai più
vent'anni ma non ce n'è più 40 non 150
non è il momento giusto e io comincio
giorno dopo giorno a prendere queste
scatole ea metterle in questo in questo
mio magazzino io con tutta la buona
volontà potrei anche aver voglia dopo un
po di tempo di dire è arrivato il
momento è adesso vado a ritirarmi fuori
quella creatività solo che è un casino
solo chi ha un casino e casino trovarla
e ancora di più è un casino utilizzarla
io mi sono accorto personalmente che
diamo non voglio sembrare offensivo però
diamo sopravvalutiamo la felicità che
potremmo raggiungere in un arco di dieci
anni e questo lo capisco perché ho
sentito tantissime volte persone di
trent'anni dire è se tornassi indietro a
quando nelle 20 poi a 40 senti porca
miseria se dessi ancora 30 anni e
probabilmente io stesso a 90 anni sarei
disposto a dare via tutto quello che ho
accumulato nella mia vita per ritornare
quel magico momento di quando ne avevo
soli 70 perché non so come mai ma l'uomo
si impegna e studia e dedica energie per
cercare in tutti i modi di allungare il
tempo ma io dico ma serve veramente
allungare il tempo
se però non si ha la consapevolezza di
come utilizzarlo il tempo io penso che
molti di noi se avessimo se avessero più
tempo farebbero forse le stesse cose
solamente per più anni senza mai
cambiare
quella allora io dico un po vedere che
la soluzione non è allungare il tempo ma
è allargare il tempo e come si fa
allargare il tempo ogni giorno inserendo
dei segni più dentro di te che sono
circondarsi di persone con il segno più
fare delle scelte con il segno più ma
soprattutto diventare noi delle persone
con il segno più
e credetemi che non bisogna essere
artisti geni pittori per fare questo
basta semplicemente andare dentro a
questo garage ea fare un po di pulizia
io penso che in questo momento se ci
fosse giovanni probabilmente alzerebbe
la mano e io gli direi aspetta perché ho
capito che è un esempio
però se ci pensiamo queste scatole che
abbiamo accumulato è vero sono
ingombranti ma sono leggerissime per che
cosa sono
c'è la crisi si stava meglio quando si
stava peggio sono pensieri e sono
pensieri negativi
e allora di giovanni direbbe a che
stefano ancora con questa storia dei
pensieri positivi e pensieri negativi
gli eletti nel libro che ho comprato in
autogrill
la settimana scorsa ancora con questa
storia io non voglio giudicare giovanni
giovanni può pensarla come vuole e io
non sono neanche nessuno giustamente per
dare dei consigli però un consiglio mi
sento oggi di poterlo dare ma forse
perché me lo voglio dare a me e io
consiglio ai giovani iniziate oggi a
fare quello che vi piace nella vita
perché fare ciò che ti piace è il
percorso più corretto per poter vivere
una vita straordinaria agli adulti
invece consiglio iniziate
oggi a fare ciò che vi piace nella vita
perchè non c'è cosa più straordinaria di
riscoprirsi in un'età dove hai le
capacità per apprezzarlo invece ai
senior consiglio iniziate oggi a fare
ciò che vi piace nella vita perché vi
meritate di capire il senso di tutto
questo ma soprattutto perché dovete
continuare ad essere i modelli da
seguire per i giovani e per gli adulti
perché vi guardano sempre per capire se
la vita è davvero così straordinaria
come dicono
sono passati trent'anni da quella
chiacchierata che feci in in cucina
quella volta è oggi visto che sono anche
qui seduti in sala volevo ringraziare i
miei perché mi hanno insegnato tutto
questo grazie
[Applauso]